brooks we're going to give you 14 idea
fragments
you don't have to use everything you
don't have to use all of them you can
throw any of them away
except one and we want to see how far
you can get into the process while
taking us through
your process the best you can and for
those of you watching if you want to
play along at home
great please do the same and we welcome
you to pause the video and see what you
can come up with
and compare your ideas to a professional
writer
okay are we ready i'm ready okay
screenwriters on your marks
so here we go 14 idea fragments
single mom single mom 500
000 500k a train
a train memory loss memory loss
what i forget
a small town in michigan small town
michigan okay the power of silence
power of silence a yellow bag
yellow bag a man with a checkered coat
man with a checkered
coat two friends who haven't seen each
other in 20 years
two friends who haven't
seen each other 20 years
an abandoned castle and uh
banned and castle butchered that
spelling of abandon that's fine
okay a life-threatening dare a
life threatening dare
a mismatched pair of detectives a
mismatched
pair of detectives
rebirth rebirth
and lastly this piece of dialogue okay
they don't realize how powerful i am
they don't
realize how powerful i am
cool
okay great so the first thing um
i'm thinking about is um what
spoke to me like when i go down these
prompts it's like what is it
um where where do i feel like i might
have a personal
take on something right single mom um my
mom was
single so that i feel something 500k is
a
significant amount of money um maybe i
mean it's sort of
you know heists and crass and sort of
material and
maybe train is a great location
certainly a big history
in um cinema history of trains or
strangers on a train
or um lots of different i actually wrote
up the first
screenplay that i wrote was a passenger
that i
that i sold was uh commuters on the l
train in chicago getting
trapped in the blizzard uh during an
alien invasion
so um but i can't do that already wrote
that one so
that's that memory loss um is certainly
interesting
um but not so much to me i'm going to
put that one aside
small town michigan okay maybe um
certainly i spent some time in the
midwest so that's possible
but probably more toward the end of the
list doesn't i'm
more called to the train and then you
later have a location with the um
the castle an abandoned castle which is
kind of interesting
um i visited england once
and um went to see a castle
and it was it's interesting it's what's
nice about that it's an elevated
location
it's sort of just could be a warehouse
right but it's you know has this history
and
um and it has all these metaphorical
powers to it so
maybe there's something there um power
of silence
that's interesting um one of the things
that makes
cinema powerful is um
you can just watch what people are doing
and you can um it can it can hit you on
a deep level
uh scorsese said uh once someplace that
i really appreciated he
he would sometimes watch his own films
if they came on tv or whatever and he
turned the sound off and just kind of
watches his shot selection which is a
really good way to focus on your subtext
what are the characters doing what do
they want
um also it's a great way to make sure
the scene construction
is is muscular and powerful if you had
the sound off
could you see what the conflict was and
what are they doing so um
yeah so there's something there
certainly lends itself well a yellow bag
i mean that was going to be used to pull
over somebody's head to kill them
okay otherwise i'll feel connected to
that
man with a check or coat that sounds
like something um
potentially could be in some sort of
detective piece or whatever i'm not that
called
about that two friends who haven't seen
each other in 20 years i am
all over that um i deep
relationships with people i went to high
school with um
and child latu and i that's probably
pretty common but there was the
i uh in nyu my senior thesis film was
about me
uh was based on when i took my
girlfriend home to my hometown
and i had really close relationships
with my guy friends and i kind of
got myself in the situation to be
choosing between my girlfriend and my
guy friend
ended up winning a screenwriting award
there um
so that's um to me that's the most
loaded and interesting
idea of everything so far right and who
knows maybe
this is two single moms who haven't seen
each other
in a long time maybe they're on a train
and maybe they're going to
rob the train for 500 000 terrible idea
but anyway that's just
um that's not where i'm going but um
single moms
i haven't seen each other in 20 years i
mean i'm not a single mom so i wouldn't
go too far into that as my protagonist
probably i can i write women they're
half the people on
half the characters in all my
screenplays so i can um
like these days me being a white
straight male
writing a single mom driven movie is you
know there's resistance there um
and it's it's other people's story so um
uh the son of a single mom my bad that i
get that's personal to me
um but these two friends haven't seen
each other 20 years they meet on a train
is definitely something that is speaking
to me see
single mom maybe um i want you maybe one
of them is traveling with their single
mom that feels personal to me
um and maybe they're going to see this
abandoned castle
in london right or outside of london so
now what i'm doing is i'm taking these
elements and i'm
connecting to things that have happened
in my life that i could
bring out authenticity with i could make
them something that
it's like what's my personal way in when
i write with this one
writing partner um you know his
superpower
is sort of creativity and inventiveness
and he loves sci-fi and fantasy
my superpower is grounded characters
person they're grounded personal
characters
and i write tension that's really thick
generally in dramas or thrillers
so when i write with him it's like
where's the double filter where do we
both
um like when we both speak to so um
and so sometimes when we're looking at
fragments it's sort of
you know when he and i are maybe
brainstorming new concepts or when i
brainstorm myself i kind of take
fragment ideas and i kind of start
and if he and i guess what reason i
brought up is if he and i are
disagreeing about something
he like kind of likes something i go
yeah but i don't have any personal
connection to it
and then we go okay fine i'm going to
the next one or vice versa so that's
what i'm looking for here when i'm
seeing these fragment ideas it's like
well what's my
what's my personal connection to it if
i'm in a general meeting with a producer
or something like i got this book
and we're thinking about bringing in a
writer to adapt it or whatever
i go great let me hear it and i'm
looking for
some sort of connection because
i can make it sing when i'm writing
about this dude i went to high school
with who fascinates me
you know that that's really what i'm
writing about and i'm just sort of
doing it in this certain way that kind
of connects so
um okay a life-threatening dare um
probably not a dare doesn't interest me
um
i'm putting that at the bottom of the
list um
next in yellow bag which i won't use a
mismatched pair of detectives
well that's sort of if i was working
with like a producer who was like i want
to do a movie and it's got to have a
mismatched parent
[Music]
all right i might you know it's part of
the you know like maybe these two
friends they meet on the train they
haven't seen her in 20 years and
something terrible happens on the train
maybe
it stops in the middle of the woods or
something and um they have to
be a mismatched pair of detectives to
figure out what they all happened
um you know i'm just kind of i'm
there's two things i'm doing i'm trying
to say what what is it that i can bring
something to from my perspective on life
um and then how do these elements sort
of piece that together but the key is
not to force it
right a mismatched pair you know
that element general mismatch para
detective feels a little
you know a little forced to me but it
can be really fascinating because
detectives are interesting if you're
doing any sort of mystery story
and mismatch is always good because
you know we all have poles inside of us
part of us that's this and part of us
that's that
and you know any sort of buddy love
story what blake snyder would call has
these two different characters learning
from each other so maybe you know
these detectives are puzzle pieces that
need to learn how
to fit together so that's possible um
that's possible
rebirth i mean that's kind of a theme um
uh sure um you know we all have rebirths
times but i wouldn't really force a
theme that much at this point i don't
think
man with sugar coat we're back to and
then they don't realize how powerful i
am
i mean there's definitely some juice
there you could do something with that
line in a certain way
um um it's kind of a heartbreaking way
to take it if you um
if the character really doesn't believe
it um the character is
in this place of going i'm not enough
i'm not good enough whatever
um and says they don't realize how
powerful i am but doesn't mean it at all
you know um the subtext of that is
really beautiful and heartbreaking
and that would maybe um yeah anyway so
um
so yeah i mean that's so you know that's
that's a little bit uh 10 minutes so
this is how i would approach it so i'm
kind of
i basically um reorganize the list and
put the ones that were like
the ones that i had some sort of
connection to more towards the top
and towards the bottom and for the
hypothetical if i was going to go for
further i would just you know if for
some you know i mean that's not how it
works i mean
working the businesses they'll say i've
got this story and maybe it has some of
these elements
um i mean it might there might be some
sort of novel that has those sort of
elements
but this is sort of missing the
narrative drive or something so
um which tends to be more the core part
of a story which is why if somebody
would option a book
or something but like
does that answer your question in terms
of how i would think about these things
in terms of putting them into a story
like if you were to take some of these
pieces
um whether you use just one what if you
just
all you did was was build it around the
two friends who hadn't seen each other
in 20 years
okay you just said okay i'm gonna take
that and you know that that
resonates with you because you have
close relationships with people from
your hometown
yeah and so okay you can go somewhere
else so you want me to come up with a
concept
uh based on um one of these pieces sure
and if one if one and if you say you
know what
actually this yellow bag what if one of
them finds 500 000 in a yellow bag
and now they have a moral dilemma do i
turn it in what do i do
yeah yeah interesting um well i'll pitch
an idea
that um these two friends are on the
train and they haven't seen each other
in um
20 years and um
um maybe they had a history of some
some bad things back in high school that
they did maybe not too bad but like some
trouble
um and one guy's desperate and he's got
an opportunity to steal 500 000 from x
right so um and he hasn't seen this guy
in 20 years
and he knows at least back the way he
was before
that like this guy is the perfect guy
it's almost like strangers in a train
which is the premise there with the
hitchcock story was um
i'll do your murder you do my murder and
that way we have no alibi
and we're both um
we're both more likely to get away with
it so maybe i would pitch this as a spin
on that but it's not
um hitchcock was great but he also had a
very kind of
you know bulk boxy sort of stiff you
know performances and kind of you know
it was just older
different different time but if it was
like a
yeah a modern story two friends that
haven't seen each other and this one
guys already has this heist in mind
and desperately needs his 500 and runs
into this
friend and is like oh my god this guy's
the perfect guy to do it
and then what's what's the blocking
agent why is um
is it the guy you know um like maybe
even like
one guy's a dirty cop right so one guy's
a dirty cop and and
the guy that sees him is now a criminal
and maybe he's trying to recruit one
guy's trying to recruit the other for
some sort of heist or something
um he's guys are best friends in high
school and um
so what i'm doing is i'm i'm sort of
pitting sort of
deeper personal elements in a way that
could feel kind of personal not that
i've ever robbed anything or anything
like that
but like um loyalties among friends
and taking some sort of risk for a heist
experience is pretty
compelling i like heist stories i like i
like crime stories so um
yeah so i could see that as sort of a i
mean it's kind of a low
low uh you know there's high concept
there's low concept
um but you know it's it's okay it's it's
interesting so if you were to so if
let's say that's the story so let's say
um
i'll write a long line out of it when
when
two friends two
they were not what kind of friends they
were um outsiders they were um
two kind of down and out friends one's a
cop we were called down and
out friends
um one cop and
one crook
who haven't seen each other in 20 years
um meet on a train
they decide to team
up to steal 500 000
right so that's functional um but like
so that's like and that's actually where
a lot of sort of
beginning writers might stop right okay
they do it and then
the but the problem is if you don't go
any further with that concept
it's just flat it's sort of like i mean
you have to that dialogue would have to
be
phenomenal and crackling and amazing um
so what really makes this better as a
concept is
who are these friends is one's a cop
what type of cop is he how how dirty is
he
and then um and if it's like this
thing where the the crook needs to the
cop for one thing and the cop needs a
crook for one thing
and then there's these loyalties that
are at play and who knows maybe um
you know maybe they stopped being
friends because one guy hooked up with
his girlfriend back in high school
um and then that comes up at a climatic
part where
one guy never really effing forgave him
for it um
you know um you know i could write a
story like that i mean again
it doesn't feel i mean i'm looking at it
for 17 minutes now but like um
uh but this is a process i would go into
it and i would say what and and i and if
i was
i would first of all i wouldn't put a
ticking ten clock at night i would kind
of play with it for a little bit and
then i would sit down and set it down
i'd go someplace else
and then was in the shower or whatever
might come to me and go okay what if
what if this happened with this guy and
then what if that happened and i would
play with it and i would get it to a
point where
um you know i felt like okay this is
something that's kind of interesting and
then i would pass it around to my
feedback circle
say what do you guys think is this um
you know i might have them rate it from
one to ten
um i might just pitch it to them and
then look at the response and if
um again i you know step one would be me
getting to a place like
that i feel like i'm really excited to
me right now what i put together is
rudimentary it's like level six out of
ten as a
sort of concepts right um it's much
easier if you start a new script and
it's like a level nine concept with a
level 10 concept
right which is unlikely for you know
most people to do when they're sitting
it's looking at something for 15 minutes
but that's the things we you know we
don't have to do this we have as much
time as we want
so um i would just keep going back to
the well and playing with it go what
about this or what about that and then
you know if i ever felt a little forced
and just put it away and then
just do something else and then once i
got it up to a point where i felt like
oh this is actually really great and and
also the other thing that i'd be looking
for
that's really good that i got from blake
snyder is irony so
where can you add some irony to the
story so two down and out friends one's
a cop one's a crook they haven't seen
each other in 20 years they meet on a
train
one guy realizes that he's super
desperate and he's got a shot
at stealing 500 000 bucks and his friend
from high school is the perfect
accomplice
but yeah they you know one guy slept
with this
they stopped talking 20 years ago
because one guy slept with his
girlfriend and um
they got to deal with that or maybe
that's got to be dealt with up front and
then he goes okay we'll do it
and that breaks into sec into your
second act um
and then as we go deeper
you know why did he sleep with the
girlfriend what did they really love
about each other
um that was betrayed back then you know
what do they really need
as people um and then the movie really
becomes about
uh you know i don't know if it comes
about a rebirth but it comes about them
sort of because i had deep friendships
in high school i mean these guys i love
these guys because partly because my
father wasn't around as much as i want
him to be so i have
abandonment stuff so one way that i
dealt with that abandonment stuff was
having really tight friendships
so um uh
my friends and i did not sleep with each
other's girlfriends but
um you know there's betrayals of
different sorts or whatever but i would
sort of tap into that
thing and it would probably have to do
with some if i was gonna write this or
develop it and i had to use those
elements
i would start playing around this idea
of abandonment and how i dealt with
abandonment and how these guys have
dealt with abandonment and what do they
do about it and
um yeah so that's kind of that's
that's what i got i mean that's sort of
my process and you know looking at it
for 20 minutes
um you know how i would approach it why
would i i would approach it that way
um and at the level that i got to this
what i will say is
a this is like i said i don't know 60
70 it feels like it's it's there if it's
what would make this from just being an
exercise to something like oh this is
amazing i want to really write this at
some point
probably another element or two maybe
there's a sense of irony that i could
bring into it
or maybe a way to elevate it maybe it
doesn't take place sort of modern day
but maybe it takes place on the moon or
the international space station or
something or it takes place in like the
1860s
and i'm in a place where i really want
to you know explore that sort of thing
but what i'm looking for is that
personal connection to it something that
i
feel like yeah i'm on the planet to do
this
you know and then another thing i would
do early on is going okay well what is
it like okay it's sort of like strangers
on the train
but like you know i admire stuff about
that but that doesn't really speak to me
um now pat garrett and billy the kid the
peck and paw film from 72 or 73
that blows me away and that's about
friendship and betrayal
so maybe i do that maybe i go in and go
okay
two friends who haven't seen each other
and maybe it's sort of like with
pacquiao and billy the kid they were
outlaws together and then they were
pitted against each other um
so maybe i would do that i would kind of
milk what i love from that comparable
and i would go okay
how would peck and paul do this how
would this happen um
so um and again the key is not forcing
it so i would never put a 20
20 minute um or whatever never put a
time limit i would i would just get in
there and play around and that get to
the point where
if it was fun to keep playing i would
and if it stopped being fun i'd just do
something else
maybe with a different story maybe
whatever um
and if i was in a meeting with a
producer and they were pitching this
idea it would still be the same thing
it's like you know i either can bring
uh something to what this you know the
guy's vision is for what he wants to do
whether it's an original or an
adaptation or something um or i can't
and
i'm not attached to either outcome you
know because it's that's the thing is
because it's
it exists beyond me it's like i'm not
even it's not me
the more i think it's like me my
screenplay blah blah blah it's like that
just gets in the way what i'm doing is
trying to be in service
to the audience that would want to see
this let's say it's a crime thriller or
a heist film
and um and if i am the man to
serve them with these sort of ideas that
just came to me
and they're in service great you know
and you want to pay me a lot of money
for that
awesome and um and i'm not i'm not
attached to anything
but you were able to find things that
you emotionally plugged into
even if it was just 60 70 percent there
like the man with the checkered coat you
were like yeah yeah whatever
abandoned castle yeah i've been to one
it was kind of cool it was eerie
but it wasn't something that you really
felt like maybe a deep connection with
but the
two friends that hadn't seen each other
that
really and why is because
my personal life
my psychology my psyche was formed
around this
abandonment issue my dad took you know
my parents split when i was in
third grade my dad died when i was 17.
so i dealt with
abandonment as a core issue
my whole life and so i have world-class
insights about how to deal with
abandonment in good ways and in bad ways
and everything in between
so um you know you got abandonment
issues you come to me and i'll
you know we'll have a good conversation
and my stories
um when they come from that place now
you know what i mean now it's like
it makes some sense right um and i can
touch on other things but like that's
that was a core one for me so that's why
those friendships meant so much to me
um and i mean it was like and i would
not only i had a
group of friends in high school but i
had like best friends and we were like
this
you know really you know a couple
different ones but like and it was
probably because i was hurting so much
because i miss my father um
so um that for a screenwriter to have
that sort of insight into whatever
however your psychology works and
however your triggers work
can then fuel the choices that you make
so they're loaded up
so that you're not just writing oh i'm
doing an action film it's like yeah
that's that but it's actually a metaphor
for this time in my life where it drove
me crazy and broke my heart and
because the movies that we
love and shows that we love are melting
our hearts because
um the people creating them are
basically sharing their
memoirs with us they're sharing their
diaries and most intimate vulnerable
places in their life
with archetypes or personified in these
characters that are iconic in a way so
that i look at goodfellas
and i feel like that's my me and my
friends and we never did anything with a
mob i grew up on
new york but like way different side of
long island
and um and there was blue color there
were similarities but again like
nothing like those guys and yet exactly
like those guys
and that's because scorsese and pelegi
were so specific with
the people that they grew up with and
they allowed that to manifest in a movie
like goodfellas
and with such delight and specificity
that um yeah it feels like
it's my story
you